you have two sons Max and Finn yes and
they just turned one yeah okay yeah
they'll be 15 months yeah let's stick
with one how are they doing what's uh
you know how are they progressing
they're I mean they're both geniuses
which is expected but they haven't said
their first word my son Max has said his
first sentences one of them he just
blurts it out across the house no
prompting no asking him questions just
you know of course he doesn't understand
anything but just out of nowhere he said
a few months ago I'm gay and I just
leaned down and I was like max we love
you
we're your parents you can tell us
anything and then weeks later he yelled
it out again and I'm gay and I was like
yeah you mentioned that
and
you don't have to keep coming out to us
we remember and yeah he a few days ago
again I'm gay he's clearly not saying
I'm gay he's he's a year old right he's
puts gas or something you know I mean
you're saying that's what homosexuality
is yes yes okay yes I am that has always
been my theory I know this could get
some comments online at least two or
three oh yeah it's a relief to find out
because I've had terrible gas
we'll get to that later
[Applause]
you